okay so the basic move is defang defang
clear check and now I give you a chance
to move Fe good
defang defang prut okay that's the basic
P you can I don't really care about the
footwork again so but it has to be
consistent so angle deviation to my left
angle of deflection to my right okay you
could do it that way right or you could
oh sorry again boom right I can go back
you see back boom and then back in So
back and back here you could boom circle
around Circle okay but the other hand is
in the fight you see how I'm I'm here
and I'm covered and my elbows are down
elbows down boom boom okay R you have to
pay attention be out of range of the
power
okay and I'm relaxed I don't let the
tension get me tension doesn't get
me
relax okay right so I Fe and so he has
some kazushi there you see okay and the
reason that that's starting to pull me
off balance cuz this foot won't move
okay if we go back and I do the spe and
look how I move you see so again he's
got his hand or whatever right and if
it's starting to pull me then I am
adding Yang to his Yang even though it's
pull pull so what I have to do is go to
zero pressure and then I can get out of
there and same thing on the knife okay
so when I feed it's not that I stay
still get ch
even even just slightly like that's
enough you see I should Mash that you
see I go around it okay same thing on
this arm so here's here's his weight do
you see oh if I roll around it then
there's no weight there you see so I'm
constantly feeling for the
pressure of my own
resistance always reconciling soft soft
[Music]
reconcile all okay try that don't get
don't get checked out don't feel your
weight come off your heels into your
toes okay but understand it that it's
cuz you just didn't move just move
you're adding the conflict you're you're
creating co-creating the conflict okay
try Okay the next one he feeds I'm here
this way pass cut check okay so it's arm
pass check cut cut that's it check B
right that's the old one this one goes
here boom
cut so it just have the knife ready to
go even if the hand is there the knife
is here okay that way once you pass you
cut right
there hand is ready to go but knife is
ready to go there's the cut so
boom same thing here boom right around
right around
reconcile this way first then this way
just like Y come in
boom that's all right
boom
good so I have my same passes here
that same p cut clear boom
elbow boom
pop she Feats and I
pass right into
it I'm not going to go here wait and and
passing right
into right into
you kind get anywhere on the upper arm
shoulder area okay all that will affect
her her B
so
right right here set
down one two and I'm looking for this
thumb cut right on the
projection okay
[Music]
you all right okay all right same thing
hold my elbow
drops boom right here so that then I do
my inward spiral
boom really quick
a short elbow hi
right don't don't go
off I'm going
around my elbow drops right when you
feel the yin space right there it's
already too lce right right about here I
start to go around it okay
again boom okay you just go around it
okay just around
it boom right there is your
opening you you it depends what your
knife does after this or where it comes
out okay so if it comes out and his arm
is below me then I'll come in and I'll
snap here
snap it's on my on my chest okay my
if my arm if my knife came out if my
knife came out like it went on top right
I can use the Tua right and I do the
same thing it's on my chest I just po
that thing okay so it's this one you're
the arm is going to be there cuz boom
when you hit that you see the arm is
there so here you snap that snap
that snap that here okay
so I'm letting it loose at the end and
kind of making a projection but just
basically doing this on the
elbow see
[Music]
okay if it's if it's super low like his
arm is super low right then you can use
your you use the other arm boom that
that
[Music]
and
is here this KN
right that's what
this and this time is sticky
do
you
feel I'm not going
here I'm not going
here Stay s STI
right you're going to have two control
points now you see this going to be
inside you use the two control
points boom two control points use the
two control points so if I was here you
see or here using the two control okay
and so rip through cut around the
back now you're ready to
throw right maybe you do the other T you
see and back
[Music]
it don't matter if it's the other side
of I don't have a cutting edge knife I
don't think I need another one you know
what I
mean and clear and back truck
okay use the two point you see feel feel
it on your NE okay that's inside
there who and then you'll just walk with
me I won't take it down do you have a
friction Point here in the friction
point with my hand and then the spine of
the knife and those movement
h